this series on 17 I let my best friends
pick my girlfriend Chris yeah it's just
teenagers bullying each other that's
what it seems like for like 30 minutes
that's crazy
and it's also bugs me out how
comfortable these kids are on camera
they're all of them super console just
be like yeah I'm Zini I like scooters
and it's just [ __ ] up what's supposed
to be a 15 year old 20 years ago that
just would not be the case no put a
camera front of a kid they're like yeah
yeah nervous this [ __ ] yeah yeah now
it's just like whatever
yeah living my Tet I remember my dad we
got a camcorder and like we got some
Video Converter and he was like we just
sent a video to my brother and cuz I
hadn't seen him in a while and like hit
and my dad's dead and he just turned it
on and I remember just sitting like
frozen in the living room and my dad's
like interviewing me basically he's like
I said tell him how old you are and I'm
just like I'm 16
he says okay
it's like Sam yeah yeah yes sounds like
ya saw the video it's pretty good don't
see how do you feel about lettuce Sam my
lawyer is not present look no comment um
you can find it in Whole Foods it's
pretty neutral man I ask you how you how
you feel about it I mean it's a
vegetable you can definitely buy it
people eat it that's a great impression
do you eat it great impression I mean I
will I would if it's in front of me yeah
yeah I didn't I wouldn't smoke it what
was that you think we're talking about
weed no play for it and Ness got a just
a fire roast on Sam was like this why
sisqó skin in the [ __ ] item store
right now okay it's like a white dude
with like like blonde hair wearing all
platinum like clothes like from the 90s
like saying like silver bright that
sounds dope yeah with like a star
backpack oh yeah and then that just goes
Sam is playing his Sam right now we
started dyeing Sam's like laughing and
I'm like I wasn't gonna say it dude he's
like you should have said it was a good
row so I'm like yeah you wouldn't seen
it coming [ __ ] and he just liked it he
like doubled over he's like oh and
people keep telling me my chapter like
Sam's hotter than you I'm like yeah but
I'm funnier than him so this sort of
makes up for it
Sam ever not worn sweatpants him a hijab
now he wears full-on jean yeah he wears
full-on pants now dude he takes him
around he's always got the sweatpants on
dude
Sam's a thought yeah I'll tell to get
mad now tell it to his face
he's a thought he actually got mad at me
the other day I couldn't believe that
cuz you cuz of the stream yeah I'm like
I'm on stream he's like I'll be home in
40 minutes he's gonna swear this isn't
the case with this it's it's printed
there's time stamps he's like I'll be
home in 40 okay I'm like cool well I got
another video cued up here I'll react
two minutes later alright get on get on
my cue I'm in the middle I might give me
ten minutes because I thought the video
was short and it wasn't he's like 20
minute video later bro I'm off I know I
saw that I'm like he's just fully
offline he he's early and now he's mad
at me he like walked in on me dudes
dudes I can turn into girl yeah girls
yeah I do that's what I'm saying I get
like I get like really emotional about
40 minutes I just get on dude stop
playing with my [ __ ] emotions are we
squatting or what I'm sorry you're too
much of a coward to commit to me
and this game right now or like when you
join so no this Lobby and there's other
dudes and there oh oh oh [ __ ] bro I
didn't know you're gonna be on dude oh
no that's cool I mean I just didn't
realize you were playing with other with
other no no you can totally we totally
do someone else is coming but he does
not to play he's got other city you can
put on there so it's no no it's fine I
got other [ __ ] to do anyways two other
guys have deeper voices than you yeah
who is this man
who are you man this is my squad partner
cypher who's talking to me right now has
he seen my Katie cuz like I don't
appreciate the tone [ __ ] I don't need
this [ __ ] no wait guys he left yes sir
then I don't you're just caught it
sounds like he's ignoring me oh hey Sam
talk to me directly get it off your
chest he's like what what's up I don't
know who's here right now yeah I haven't
meted what does he say it's like he's
like Spock telling a wall I'm not
talking right now
[Music]
those crazy you guys worked things out
we did yeah I made him stop complaining
okay I'm like just get off your chest
say what you got to say and then they
argued for a little bit nice we hugged
it out it's nice to have like a nice
open conversation like that yeah just
you know then he died and I took all his
guns yeah nice we actually we all took
his guns and we were laughing about it
and then yes you know we had like his
reboot card I can bring people back it
what's the deal with that how does that
work just copied apex but what is a
reboot card so like someone dies you get
their card and then you can find a van
and then like the van takes like 10
seconds and then you can reboot
whoever's cards you have gotcha
yeah and the van and it takes up an
inventory slot mm-hmm no no no it
doesn't ok whole team has it but it was
a then well after we took all his guns
he's like give me my guns back gave my
guns back and we're all like what guns
it was just so amazing how fast we
turned on a bully
flex
not trying to flex and I'm holding half
his Bank I'm trying to flex not trying
to flex take your vision notion break
that's not a flex